so I have been sent a copy of the
graffiti DC vertigo edition of The
Sandman overture and I've got my box
here first things first box and
beautiful label on the box I haven't
opened it and I'm kind of excited and I
just wanted you to get the sense even
before it's opened of the enormous size
of this thing
it's quite possible of course that I
will open it and discover it's all
padding okay so it's just enough padding
to make sure that corners don't get
bashed in transit that's the size of it
this amazing green it is a book with j
j-- williams his name on the cover
Sandman gallery edition and j j-- his
name is on the side and mine isn't and i
am so good with that because this is
essentially the art that JH
in Sandman overture this is
and say they just look at the size of
this one of the things that I got to see
when Jake was doing this was how he
would do with some of the stuff in black
and white some of us have me blacks and
whites and grays and sometimes he just
go into color himself even though he
knew that this stuff would you challenge
this illustration I was actually given X
so James has done an introduction and
now makes the art without any of those
messy word balloons on them filled with
words so if you want to know the story
you are going to still need your coffee
of Sam an overture this is just your
getting to experience it as I
experienced it because I was seeing
these things on computers Jake would
take photos and send them over to me
oh my gosh there's
that shot which is of course then we get
this she's four sheets of paper wide as
dream encounters incarnations of himself
this is absolutely one of the most
beautiful art objects I have ever got to
hold talking glory through the Ruby get
changes covers in Kirby and Mobius and
all the other things I got to ask them
to do the joy of doing this with him for
me was that whatever I asked him to do
you would do so here is a book it's in
full color even though sometimes that is
full color black and white its
reproductions of what he did it's the
most gorgeous book I cannot wait to sit
and just spend time looking at it going
through delighting in it and exalting it
okay I was wrong it's actually the
complete colors and letters pages are in
the back so if you don't have a copy of
salmon overture you can read it in the
back here and see colored lettered
versions
and you still have all of the art the
biggest weirdest most wonderful Sandman
story I ever really got to tell that was
thank you for coming to my unboxing
thank you